joins us now here he is the greatest
defensive player in the National
Football League Pittsburgh's own Aaron
Donald he's looking a lot a perfect time
got that chin new change last year I
don't know how much you pay attention to
us Aaron Donald but I will tell you this
between Chris Sims and me you have fans
for life we recognize greatness and you
are greatness epitomized and it is great
to have you with us
I appreciate you thanks for having me I
think you really are like the UU to me
have created a stat we talk about a lot
in football because your greatness goes
way beyond the stats like I always talk
about you know I can't say the word I
call it the f up the placed an all right
because you ruin so many play designs
somebody else gets the tackle but you
have no statistic for it and I really
think they need to invent the category
because of somebody just like you you
know just just trying to be disruptive
you know trying to do everything I can
you know affect the play slow play down
at home you know you tend to do that you
players tend to make play you turn it
you know make big plays intend to win
games so that's how I play I like
negative plays to sound like oh I may
have told you this when you were with us
in Minnesota a couple years ago but your
general manager les Snead
he actually was relieved when you were
holding out from offseason work because
they could get things done because they
came to me do a walk-through with Aaron
Donald around he blows up the walk for
her you know you got to push you guys
you know we all try to make each other
better you know so you know always went
bad my dad always told me you know you
passed away you play so I'm always at
that Mantella mentality when I'm out
there you know on the field practicing
and just trying to you know work on my
craft and trying to you know have
success so you're the best I don't care
who wins NFL defense MVP you're still
the best player in the football it's
just true I think we've talked about
this a lot this year I mean get it
because you didn't get to the playoffs
and we know that's part of the whole
thing but you're still the best in the
game it was a guy that Aaron Donald like
gets wowed by on defense in football
there's a lot of guys yeah I'm always
watching a dilemma yeah no you got
flexion like that's right you got it
explosive big and that can move and do
all the different things
JJ Watt consistently no dominate you
know Joey Bosa both for the Bosa
brothers right freaks they like they
like twins
they rush the same they walked the same
so that's a pretty good players man but
not watch a lot of players you know and
just from afar you know watch their
success and you know some time watching
them motivate me to go do something on
Sunday so um there's a lot of guys in
league I know I said a lot of name well
I've been saying like Chris Jones is
like I'm watching a film of him cuz he
got he got technique with him you know
he can do a lot of different things
right um you know he's definitely God
that I watching I respect so yeah do you
pick things up watching other great
players that you actually add to your
game um you try but everybody's
different you know there's a mood that a
guy that mastered and great at that you
know probably my body type kick it won't
won't do because I'm not you know and
got the longest arms you know but you
know you just got to stand your own lane
pretty much but you watch things that
guys do and you China you know do it
with your own type a little sway with it
so well where's your like freak out
lettuce doesn't come from who is it mom
dad what I mean we're we're I would say
both most it back in linebacker since
Lully so growing up always thought I'd
be a running back you know but you know
it's a you know started playing defense
and I'm probably when I was around 12 13
and just been stuck there ever since
yeah yeah yeah when you line up what are
you sense from offensive linemen they
have to just be like oh god why this
week why do I have to try to stop making
sure the center console anyway so um you
know you play good good linemen that you
know that's confident but you know they
still can have a game plan today they
trying to find ways that you don't
disrupt the game and make them big plays
so um no it's definitely tough
definitely this season got a lot more
attention so like I tell people running
I definitely had to work for this year
you know name they make it easy on me at
all so know we got enough time for one
more break I want you 49ers Chiefs
oh no actually here we're gonna do yeah
we got to take a radio break but we're
gonna hold you through we a little TV
segment will do after that but Aaron
Donald the man and I'll tell you what
that that necklace that it's got the
Fort Pitt bridge the Golden Triangle
that is awesome if I had money I'd buy
one he's gonna give it to me when he's
out of here
continuing with errand donald Rams
offensive tackle best defensive player
in the National Football League here on
pft lock before we go any farther you're
here on behalf of Snickers tell us which
have going on I'll marry with Snickers
you know put Moton a new commercial
you know everybody see all that as they
always have you know um you know if you
had a sort and eat a Snickers so angry
right so it's more um you know the war
without a sort you know feed a world of
Snickers you know so it's a big hole you
you see the commercial you know you dump
the Snickers in there and trying to make
the world a little better so cool
commercial funny commercial and I'm just
happy to be a part of it yeah the 49
year you had the Chiefs in that epic
regular-season game last year in LA what
would you tell 49ers defensive players
about how to get there their arms around
Patrick mahomes um you just you'll be a
guy who's gonna be calm and cool you
know even if you do get to them so um
you know hopefully you know you just get
to them you know find ways to get to get
the ball out you know I think he gonna
make a lot of good decisions with the
ball you know anytime you play a good
quarterback they go make good this is
with the football but um you know you
could do a lot of things different
things you know you can run in the park
you can make a lot of good throws on the
run um oh we got his ass down field so
you know he's definitely tough got a
play we talked about this like a little
bit about containing him like do you
watch film with a quarterback to see
like the moves he pulls or the body
language he has to escape and stuff like
now you definitely watch to see how you
move you know and a Fiat guy you know
there's there's like Jackson and I could
do it all you kind of be like alright
you got to prepare yourself for it but
when you play quarter bus mobile the one
thing people do they always want to
break down and check you get you just
got to go trying to get them the faster
you can right you can't make it the
decision where you gonna go what are you
gonna do so right you do that a lot of
people want to break down and do this
and that's how you're done you get shook
you're done well Aaron we didn't see you
last year because you were in the game
so here's hoping we don't see you next
year
because you'll be getting ready for the
game you're not available to come by
Aaron Donald but great defensive tackle
bass player
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports